Describe la expresión radical
usando exponentes racionales y simplifica.
Y aquí tenemos la raíz cuarta de "5a" cuarta
"b" elevada a la potencia 12
y el punto clave a considerar aquí,
es que si tengo la raíz cuarta
de algo
esto es igual a ese algo,
elevado a la un cuarto,
o en general
si tengo la raíz enésima de algo,
esto es igual a ese algo elevado a la potencia 1 entre "n",
podemos aplicar eso aquí.
La raíz cuarta de todo esto,
es igual a "5a" a la cuarta
"b" a la doceava potencia
y todo eso elevado a la potencia un cuarto.
Y también sabemos que si tomamos
el producto de algo y lo llevamos un exponente,
eso es igual a si tomamos
cada uno de esos términos del producto,
y lo elevamos por separado
a ese exponente,
y después, hacemos el producto,
hagamos eso,
esto es igual a 5
elevado a la potencia un cuarto, por,
"a" a la cuarta elevada a la potencia un cuarto por
b a la doceava elevada a la potencia un cuarto.
Ahora
5 a la un cuarto,
esto no sé cuánto es,
pero es lo mismo que la raíz cúbica de,
no...
lo puedo dejar como 5 a la un cuarto potencia,
y "a" no se puede simplificar,
o lo puedo reescribir,
como la raíz cuarta de 5.
Ahora, "a" a la cuarta,
elevado a la un cuarto potencia.
Si tienes algo que lo elevas a una potencia,
y luego a otra potencia,
eso equivale a elevar "a" la potencia cuatro por un cuarto.
Déjame escribirlo acá abajo.
Así es que esto es "a"
elevado a la potencia cuatro por un cuarto.
Y finalmente aquí.
Usando exactamente la misma propiedad de los exponentes, esto es igual a
"b" elevado a la potencia 12 por un cuarto.
Así que todo esto se simplifica como...
y aquí voy a cambiar
el orden en el que tenemos estos términos,
esto es igual a la raíz cuarta de 5,
luego tenemos "a"
elevado a la potencia 4 por un cuarto,
lo cual se simplifica como
"a" a la potencia 1,
que se escribe simplemente como "a"
y luego aquí tenemos "b"
elevado a la potencia 12 por un cuarto,
bien, 12 por un cuarto es 3,
así es que eso es, "b" cúbica
y nuestros resultados finales entonces
"a" por "b" cúbica por la raíz cuarta de 5.